really one of the great interviews of
all time by the way shortened Peters
there's a new book out 12 rules for life
that clip is everywhere George Peterson
joins us tonight it's an honor to have
you professor so I've watched you for a
while I've always thought you were a
truth teller one of the chapters in your
book is tell the truth that's one of
your rules what are some of the things
that you think we're forced to lie about
in this moment well I don't know if
we're forced I think we make a choice
that it's it's sometimes a bitter choice
but that's often the case when you're
deciding what to say but my sense is
often you're in a situation where you're
damned if you do when you're damned if
you don't so you might as well pick the
poison you'd rather take and that and
you you have a moral obligation to do
that so you know if you're gonna say
something unpopular and you're gonna get
attacked for it the that's a risk but to
shut up and pretend that you think
something different is to warp your soul
and that's a much bigger risk so yes it
is so why I would think that even if
they didn't agree with you that people
in the media would be thrilled by the
way you can port yourself the way you
respond because clearly you're saying
what you really think and that's
supposed to be our charge as journalists
is to tell the truth well yet you get
met with these hostile receptions why do
you think that is well I would say
that's not Universal there's a big
battle being played out in the press say
over the Kathy Newman interview there
are people who are casting her as a
victim because she's being vilified as a
consequence of the interview but there's
been many many people in the media who
stood forth and and and said that it's
necessary to be able to say what you
think so it's not a battle that's over
yet yeah it's good it's good
surprising but good so if you in the
book you have a number of these rules in
rule five just jumped out at me as a
father you said here's a rule don't let
your children do anything that makes you
dislike to them mm-hmm what does that
mean well it means first of all that you
should understand that you are actually
capable of disliking your children and
that because you're larger and more
powerful than them if you let them
misbehave in a way that makes you
dislike them you're gonna take revenge
on them in a very bad way and sometimes
over decades I've seen that as a
clinical psychologist but more
importantly if your children behave in
ways that make you dislike them assuming
you're reasonable and that might be
something you wanted to
des with your wife then other people are
gonna dislike them two are their adults
and then they won't teach them things
and they won't pay attention to them and
they'll only smile falsely at them and
other children won't want to play with
them and include them and that's a
catastrophe for your child so it's very
helpful to help your children behave in
ways that make other people welcome them
because then everywhere they're go
they're welcome and there's nothing
better you can do for a child than that
very smart in the minute we have left if
you could pass on one piece of life
advice and this really is a book of life
advice to our viewers what would it be
stop saying things that make you weak
what does that mean well if you pay
attention to what you say you'll you'll
know that sometimes you feel like you're
standing on a rock that you're in a
solid place and I suppose that you're
speaking from your heart and other times
you're saying things just to look good
and just to the buttress your particular
status at the time and that makes you
feel weak you sell yourself out and if
you pay attention to what you say you
can tell when you're making yourself
stronger and you can tell when you're
making yourself weaker and unless you
want to be weaker than I would say it's
best to say those things that make you
strong and you can learn to do that and
it's really useful so I would recommend
practicing that because it's good for
you and good for everyone else too and
so there's a there's a reason people
obsessively watch your YouTube videos
professor thank you very much for
joining us Congrats on the book thanks
very much